[Musique]
voilà trois jours que tout Hollywood ne
parle que de cette gifle
si Will Smith a tenu à s'excuser auprès
de Chris Rock dans un message Instagram
dès le lendemain de la cérémonie en
comportement la nuit dernière aux Oscars
était inacceptable et inexcusable je
voudrais publiquement te demander pardon
Christ ce que j'ai fait était déplacé et
j'ai eu tort il y a assez sa femme jade
à Pinkett Smith qui est sorti du silence
en jouant la carte de l'apaisement c'est
une saison pour la guérison et je suis
là pour ça mais simple phrase en
commentaire comme pour mettre fin à la
polémique pourtant cette gif continue de
faire réagir et l'acteur Jim Carrey
s'est dit écurie d'un tel comportement
de la part de Will
Smither
94e cérémonie des Oscars n'a pas fini de
faire parler
[Musique]
et donc ça va polluer d'abord cette
cérémonie parce qu'on sait même pas qui
a gagné quoi par c'est fou à part oui
cette claque et donc du coup moi je
trouve que c'est marrant oui c'est honte
de dire ça de la part de Jim Carrey et
c'est en train de se retourner aux
États-Unis moi c'est plein de sondages
alors il y a un Américain sur 3 qui
trouve que la violence n'est pas
acceptable mais chez les jeunes ouais il
y a 57 % des 18 34 ans qui disent que le
coupable celui qui a fauté ses Chris
Rock
et alors les jeunes c'est vraiment ceux
qui font écouter
moi je suis d'accord avec Will Smith et
bien sûr moi aussi j'ai raté la violence
la défendu sa femme
voilà mais tu es malade
bon alors d'abord on va se calmer sur
trois choses petite teint peu on va
quand même dire les choses petites c'est
un couple qui allait très mal mais je
veux juste pas je juge pas
il y a trop pris dans tous les sens se
coupent très mal parce qu'il l'a trompé
6 fois ensemble donc effectivement il se
tromperie un couple libre ça c'est tout
le livre c'est toi
[Rires]
en fait non lui lui il est en couple et
voilà voilà petit 2 c'est horrible ce
qui lui arrive c'est une alopécie c'est
une perte de cheveux c'est effectivement
très très triste et je comprends sa
douleur et elle a pas non plus elle est
pas un cancer en phase terminale c'est
pas non plus voilà et petit 3 et petit 3
Benjamin qui a cru bon l'ouvrir pour la
première fois aujourd'hui dit c'est pas
de la violence un coup de poing dans la
gueule c'est quoi Benjamin c'est pas un
coup de poing alors c'est quoi alors
qu'est-ce que c'est une jupe
c'est de l'amour pour sa femme
qui bat sa femme on lui dit parce que
merci merci
qui doit souffrir il a eu mal pour elle
il s'est levé pour la venger sur Jim
Carrey vous dites quoi c'est un immense
connard Jim Carrey quelque chose alors
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'en France à
partir de maintenant tous les humoristes
qui feront une blague de mauvais goût
sur quelqu'un ou sur la femme d'un
acteur ou de quelqu'un
ils ont tourné ensemble ils pouvaient
pas saquer et il le cherche à chaque
fois au bout d'un moment quand tu
cherches quelqu'un tu le trouves il a
pris une classe alors si Roger avait mis
un coup de canne à quelqu'un
parce qu'il vous parle mal est-ce que ça
vous plaît Delphine non parce que moi
non plus je suis pas pour la violence on
peut parler voilà entre hommes voilà on
peut dire
non je répète
non j'aurais pas aimé moi ça m'aurait ça
m'aurait mis la honte
je pense que deux hommes peuvent parler
ensemble et puis et puis nous les femmes
on peut aussi se défendre si on a besoin
de de dire quelque chose la violence
la violence blesse les mots tuent les
Noirs non c'est pas pollueur du tout pas
du tout non plus
je viens de dire
ment dans son oreille
oui batterie moi je pense que c'est Jada
qui est abus parce que j'adore
elle a mis un bordel pas possible dans
tout Hollywood dans les Oscars Academy
etc même dans le pays entier parce que
tout le monde et elle ne soutient pas
son mari non seulement ça mais on avait
vu les images lui riait à la blague
jusqu'à ce qu'il voit sa tête à elle qui
lui a demandé d'intervenir et le
lendemain elle elle arrive comme une
fleur et elle dit Oh excessive
voilà
donc elle récupère tout ça et elle se
pose ça veut dire ça veut dire c'est la
saison
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'il veut lui donner une
leçon de psychologie féminine non merci
c'est bon
c'est pas le coq qui va nous apprendre à
savoir ce qu'ils aient alors vas-y
c'est une magnifique déclaration d'amour
qu'elle a fait j'adore bien sûr et vous
n'y comprenez rien du tout c'est sobre
c'est efficace la guérison de ma maladie
j'espère la guérison de la dispute entre
hommes bien sûr la guérison de mon
couple aussi elle est sobre qui est
lucide là-dedans c'est Chris Rock
pourquoi parce qu'il sait qu'il faut pas
en rajouter et parce qu'il en profite
les places ça fait 15 fois que vous le
dites j'ai jamais dit que les places
aujourd'hui
et lui et lui ne fait aucune déclaration
commence par regarder ta femme et puis
après tu nous expliqueras la psychologie
féminine aujourd'hui
n'importe quoi elle aurait pu soutenir
son mari il a quand même fait ça par
amour Will Smith lui il a fait un poste
en disant je ne supporte pas qu'on se
moque de ma femme elle fait même pas
référence à lui moi je trouve ça
dégueulasse franchement et parce qu'il
est temps de plus elle lui envoie
mais c'est ça la vraie histoire qui ne
va pas du tout c'est un faux couple
comme les Beckham ils sont restés
ensemble c'est un faux couple quoi il a
été voir ailleurs partout c'est un
couple qui ne s'aime plus c'est pas
compliqué
de Beckham ah c'est gentil au moins bien
c'est plus David Beckham
mais je vous avais dit que c'est ce que
j'avais dit que c'est ce que ma vidéo
Elton John a donné
quand il est arrivé au restaurant tu es
venu me voir il m'avait dit vous
ressemblez étrangement à David Beckham
c'est de là qui était parti dans une
conversation et qu'il avait invité dans
sa maison mais oui et après tu as été
like candle in the wind
Raymond ça va moi ça va très bien alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans cet endroit là dans cette cérémonie
là avec que des enfants gâtés se lever
comme ça à mettre une tarte à un mec il
sait très bien que le mec il va rien lui
faire derrière et après il s'assoit
derrière et après il pleure et il danse
il s'excuse il fait tout et n'importe
quoi on n'était pas dans un film il aura
du reste à sa place à la limite il
l'attrape horloge il dit encore une
vanne sur ma femme je te casse la bouche
et c'était mieux comme tu le dis en
anglais en anglais alors là en anglais
non mais j'ai pas j'ai pas trop aimé
parce que le message il est pourri la
preuve regarde derrière ça fait tout un
foin et non mais est-ce que dans la rue
quand on l'insulte et ce qui sortent sa
voiture pour mettre des Baffes à tout le
monde je crois pas il reste la fenêtre
fermée c'est Will Smith il a sa vie et
bien là ça vide-grâter il a des garde du
corps il est très bien je trouve que il
m'a il m'a je je l'aime Luis mais il m'a
déçu sur ce truc là il aurait dû rester
classe digne passe lever mettre une
baffe comme ça je crois que c'est pour
deux fois moi je dis il n'a pas touché
j'ai regardé avec la box là je faisais
retour et je m'étais pose à chaque fois
j'ai de la pas touché c'est pas possible
c'est une vanne c'est un sketch d'accord
je crois qu'il l'avait pas touché et je
me dis vous pensez qu'il avait touché je
pensais qu'il avait pas touché
ou que c'était un livre tu vois et même
quand tu l'as dit ah là je suis lancé ça
y est tu m'as bien sûr
tu as dit c'est une vanne et tout je dis
oui c'est obligé que ce soit une vanne
oui Suisse il peut pas se lever comme ça
mais tu me car il a été dur hein
j'aurais préféré qu'il mette une baffe
et qui disent à sa meuf allez lève-toi
prends les clés de la voiture on se
barre de là et c'est pas barré il est
resté après la cérémonie il a dansé il a
pleuré qui fait un autre banane ben
j'aurais préféré qu'ils mettent ça bave
qui prennent sa femme et qu'ils allaient
on se barre de cette soirée de merde
après sur Jim Carrey il dit qu'il porte
faut qu'il porte plainte ça va changer
quoi de porter plainte parce que tu vois
parce que moi je suis prête
les gens de se lever pour mettre des
bases c'est le principe de la justice
il prend une amende de 200000 dollars
oui donc on passe de tous les noms si tu
sais l'oseille qui compte alors c'est
plus l'amour de ma part du tout mais si
tu sais que tu vas avoir une amende tu
te lèves plus mais tu judiciaire c'est
normal
même si tu insultes ma femme si j'y vais
je te bave je pense pas je pense pas
l'argent du procès et ben la prochaine
fois je te demande si tu prends deux
sommet de balle tu repenseras la
présidente
pour être des donneurs de leçons
voilà c'est des donneurs de leçons hein
le fils il se la raconte à mort
et donc voilà et donc Chris Rock ça
avait saoulé en 2016 quand ils étaient
donneurs de leçons et qu'ils ont
boycotter les Oscars et voilà
défoncer et il a surtout fait une vanne
pas très sympa sur Jada en disant Jada
qui boycotte les Oscars c'est comme moi
qui boycote le slip de Rihanna j'étais
pas invité donc voilà allez superbe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gentils ah ouais mais je te promets les
vrais gens
les gentils les les gentils dans la vie
sont enfin les gentils à l'antenne sont
méchant dans la vie et les méchants la
peine sont gentils dans la vie Will
Smith il arrive tout sourire tout na na
c'est pas gentil Will Smith voilà mais
non tu connais pas tu le connais pas
alors d'abord je pourrais qu'est-ce qui
vous dit que beaucoup de monde je
connais beaucoup de monde j'ai un très
beau d'abord je connais Elton John mais
j'ai de très bon ami à moi qui a passé
une soirée avec Will Smith voilà et qui
me dit qu'effectivement il est très
caractériel je veux pas dire ceci mais
moi je pense que c'est un gros mytho
déjà je connais j'ai connu Julio
Iglesias j'ai connu Elton
il est très caractériel